accuse killer Robert Tellis can
represent himself at his murder trial
that's according to a ruling from the
judge but will that
that happen
to this high-profile criminal case which
if convicted tell us could face life in
prison Robert tell us admitting he has
zero experience in criminal trials let
alone a murder case but still insisting
he wants to represent himself you want
to represent yourselves Jennifer yeah
Robert tell us now parting ways with a
third attorney the former Clark County
public administrator is accused of
killing investigative journalist Jeff
gearman last September German had
exposed problems under the leadership of
Telus untilis then lost the Democratic
Primary in court Monday I don't think
anyone ever does a good job representing
themselves Clark County District Court
Judge Michelle Levitt repeatedly warning
tell us it's a bad idea to represent
himself he says he's been a lawyer for
seven years but mainly in civil law Tel
is saying he wants a trial date sooner
than it's scheduled for in November he
and his attorney aren't agreeing on the
timeline and he initially indicates
representing himself would be temporary
represent myself as
for at least a couple of months while I
make sure that I'm in a position to hire
another attorney because again okay
so Mr tell us when I'm playing games
you're not gonna wrap
if you want to hire someone else that's
fine I'm going to give you an
opportunity to do that well I want to
represent myself around here's what he
told us in an interview from jail a few
weeks ago hoping at this point
to solicit an attorney that you know can
can go ahead and look at the case and
and you know again give me Justice and
then give
you know everybody some closure some
justice on this sooner rather than 10
months from now Telus also claims he was
framed despite evidence police point to
like DNA tying him to the scene Vanessa
Murphy 8 news now so the next scheduled
court date is March 9th and that's to
talk more about that standby Council
Vanessa was referring to now this is
someone who wouldn't represent tell us
but an attorney who would be on standby
at the trial to help provide guidance
tell us also telling judge today that
he's hired an investigator despite also
previously claiming that he is innocent
Indigent I should say